why Asaf been chosen india to expand its
energy business this is a huge huge deal
here good morning
I think India is the only major economy
in the world at the moment which has got
power blackouts on its grid
it has 300 million people with no access
to the electricity grid and it's a major
growing economy so all the combined
makes it a very energy hungry nation
plus as you rightly said Prime Minister
Modi's ambition to install 100 gigawatts
of solar and 60 gr of wind makes it a
really exciting market for all foreign
investor and that's why I think
softbank's choice for India and the
solar and wind market well maybe just
tell us a bit more how different is this
from the core businesses of Softbank
Bharti and Foxconn I think fundamentally
quite different because if you look at
the internet and telecoms business when
you acquire customers you have ongoing
competition to do that and also once you
acquire consumers you have to service
them considering it continuously and
face competition
compare that to power generation
business specially solar power
generation business in India where there
is competition to get hold of the
projects and win the projects and
government tenders but once you do that
and get the land and the project is up
and running then you face a very stable
and predictable cash flow and hence a
very stable and predictable return on
equity so very very fundamentally
different businesses yeah and maybe just
run us through the advantages and
disadvantages of this project I mean
you're talking about finding at ninety
four billion dollars needed to pay for
this clean energy overhaul absolutely in
fact with the announcement if Softbank
party and Foxconn are able to commit 20
billion dollars in this project or joint
venture then it will automatically
become one of the biggest such
initiatives in the Indian power market
now when you have such kind of a
position then obviously you can bargain
well with your virtual suppliers as well
as in India you usually face a very high
interest rate or cost of debt which will
be kind of easily negotiable with
such kind for capital availability so
essentially I think that those are the
advantages the disadvantages obviously
there is strong competition and to find
the right projects at the right in the
right states and the right locations
will take a bit of time so I think it
will be for another 12 months to 18
months till you see the first project up
and running from this venture